hello everyone and welcome to red lips
orange car the podcast once every two
weeks three people get together to talk
about the weirdest misconnections
listings that they could find online
I'm your host a lot of Pierce I'm joined
by Marty sleeve oh hello and Zach Ryan
hey this is a show where we go through
miss connections that we found on
Craigslist oh she me both also looked on
Craigslist yes I don't I think did
Craigslist create miss connections I
think Craig himself before no she like
regular Craigslist yeah who is it I was
like like an older no you're actually
being serious yeah I met him on a shoot
I did a shoot for like an Obama
fundraising campaign and he was one of
the guys that we interviewed to say he
was on the list misconnections probably
started in newspapers right sure I would
assume so yeah it's an honor man seeking
woman
Craigslist yeah money yes you want to
start today you don't know what you're
gonna be talking about so yeah that's
the format of the show is we each bring
a misconnection and the other ones do
not know what it's about correct so many
sad somebody's gonna be happy Oh mines
some of them it just dick pics
some of them are dick pics yeah doesn't
come across well in radio subscribe so
mine was from the endemically end of
December up in the same Cisco Bay area
and it was a man seeking woman 34
Renaissance Faire oh the text goes I was
struck by the blue lights coming off of
your hat I was an attendant at the
haberdashery your eyes and smile caught
me off guard I was so struck by your
attitude not shy but subdued and
friendly I was sad to see you go without
asking for your phone number which I
feel like is a Renaissance Fair faux pas
because technology doesn't exist good
point I was hoping you would stop by
again but alas you did not have been
thinking about you ever since I would
like to see you again for much longer so
we may get to know each other my name is
Matt and I was the one with the glasses
and the bowler hat that made a comment
about the blue lights on your hat can we
break down the blue lights on the hat
situation there is it there is an
absolute obsession of the blue lights on
the hat and I'm trying to figure out
what that means yeah what is that like
maybe it's like some kind of like
sparkly crown situation and that's weird
but I'm just trying to figure like so
this man he was working the haberdashery
booth yeah and that popular
he was working it yeah okay wanna look
at jealous now
okay of him getting a job at a
Renaissance Fair I seems like that would
be I said I feel like the barrier to
entry to working at the haberdashery at
a Renaissance Fair very low I would I
would gladly give up a weekend to work
at a hat store yeah so that's the thing
she works at a haberdashery and behind a
hat from that's what oh I feel like if
she had bought the Hat it would be in
the bag you know and he'd be like you
bought a hat for me he would give that
detail but sure yeah but right thing
he's a real hat but he's clearly that
but I feel like that's like it's such a
like an easier way to make an
introduction yeah sure there's a
transaction there already it's like by
the way I think you're very attractive
well isn't that overstepping your bounds
of like the oh I don't know customer
customer II what's a custody like no
customers buy something like us t sells
it it's like doctor-patient know the
person who sells a hat at a habit -
sorry is the custody if you listen you
know if you're listening to this
inaugural episode of red lips orange car
please google the word custody custody
Rusty's less is it with two E's probably
but do you guys like dije best result is
for a man whose last name is cust oh
yeah Custer's last stand he was up
terrible let's not go over what that was
okay that was a custody is a custom-made
or personalized t-shirt
wow you really nailed it yeah
do you think that's overstepping his
bounds yeah III - kinda back back
because I feel like yeah maybe that's
not i've worked retail before and i
don't think that I would ever use it as
an opportunity to be like oh hey you're
really attractive let me get your number
or something cuz that's like a weird
position to put anybody in sorry I
apologize I've worked in a I worked at a
coffee shop for several years before
getting in the games industry and I
never asked out of customer you never
you never wrote your your number in like
latte foam in LA this is a smudge it's
like oh I'll just say it's an honest in
area code I'm sorry my name is more
sleepin I think you're a very attractive
woman please call me at this number
all info Monty haven't you like dated
women who have been at the pause what
you do trivia
yeah I've dated many custom frettin from
renascence v right nice with I feel like
knowledge in the biblical sense okay so
he works I mean the thing that's tough
here is it can't even be like hey come
back and visit me so I think the way
Renaissance Fairs work that's probably
wrong yeah like I don't know I've never
been to a Renaissance Faire so I don't
know how this works so a question one is
is the etiquette of giving your number
when you're working somewhere I think
the answer is no because that's how you
making a customer uncomfortable surely
you should not do that
I think but question to you trying to
[ __ ] her in Asansol
yeah yeah yeah well then he missed his
chance yeah he's gotta wait til next
year
so what are they what do you think the
odds of this misconnection ever
happening are like do you think there's
a chance this guy finds his well I feel
like the light thing is specific enough
then yeah this person would have to get
on Craigslist misconnections well isn't
it is very pop I haven't been on for
seven years and the only reason I jumped
on was because you were like hey we're
doing this podcast that's true yeah but
I mean is a Renaissance Faire just I
know it to me that's like a it's like a
fancy LARPing carnival yeah but you're
drunk it's not that fancy I've been
drugged at carnivals my friend good
point yeah yeah so I think people
Twitter not LARPing I know you are but
you're also I it's the fancy is the word
I took issue with oh I just meant
fancier than like a county I mean just
because you're wearing a bustier doesn't
mean that you're fancy right wow that's
a lady yeah
do you think people go to them with the
intention of coconut I'm sure there's
some I think there's probably some
people are like I want to [ __ ]
I like coz I wanted to see sword fights
yeah that way none some people want to
participate there were just who does
justice justice yes justice justice I
haven't been to a Renaissance Faire but
as a child
to medieval times oh that was great sure
not the same thing
no evil times is like a restaurant
tournament of the yes they totally [ __ ]
out every single one of the people doing
that together that's a big thing when
people talk about in theater but like if
you were like a part of the theater kid
they all just have a bunch of sex oh
yeah when I was in finally when I was in
high school is a theater kid and
everyone [ __ ] everybody right in
theater yeah except me I didn't [ __ ]
anybody okay go get your next year sport
all right do we have to these are gonna
be like we talked all night but I didn't
get you you know I didn't get your
number and that's one of those ooh maybe
this will work but this was he said I
was struck by your I was so struck by
your attitude not shy but subdued and
friendly the word dude the word subdued
is like shot not shy but subdued and
friendly yeah so again that could just
be body language maybe they never had a
conversation but yeah but also like I
feel like my default in life is not shy
but subdued and friendly
I give Vic I'm generally like I calm
subdued and friendly in public I don't I
don't necessarily think that marty is
not not not calm we hung out we hung out
all day in Portland today was I not
subdued and friendly
I don't know that subdued is the right
one what are you what do you think that
word means
calm you didn't you guys just think it
means calm man subdued is like a little
bit like internalized like taking it
back well like subdued I think more I
think Uyghurs Marty I think subdued
means that you're just kind of like
chilled out yeah he did for those I did
hang loose with hang loose which is
where the bullhorn fingers are doing
this they could hear two air revelations
I think subdued and I think of it almost
more as like less of a description and
more of a verb when you're subdue
incoming yeah
yeah what to do like a cop way or like
yeah we're like it so now that's just
straight-up murder or like a kids like
have enough he's having a tantrum trying
to subdue him yeah okay so subdued quiet
and rather reflective or depressed no
yet though that's why I say like that's
why it's like almost my rose yeah
synonyms like sambal low-spirited Duncan
yeah just yeah I think that was me yeah
say you're jovial oh yeah
so we way to describe some yeah what was
the other thing that he said subdued him
what uh not shy but subdued infer not
shy but subdued so didn't friendly
seemed to sort of like at odds with each
other yeah yeah yeah but it could also
be like you don't seem vain who subdued
yeah I don't I think they had a
conversation I'm guessing he just really
likes her had what that happy so he owns
does my name is Matt and I was the one
with glasses and the bowler hat okay so
we're gonna habit Ashley why use your
neck a bowler hat is like of the
Renaissance era right no like do you
think that's like putting the best foot
forward of like you like if you work at
like nor tease Nordstrom's for those
like if you were like halo sales if
you're just not if you're like look like
a like a schlub that's gonna buy your
wares and so like if your whole job is
to like pedal hats to the Renaissance
yeah ponies like did you is a bowler hat
gonna do it
you should making fun of this man's hat
now I'm just saying is a bowler hat the
best foot forward to get no I feel like
as a bowler hat appropriate no like nice
try corner with a big plume or something
is the way to go at a Renaissance Fair I
agree yeah I like the plume yeah but who
knows maybe there's a lot of plumes
floating around at a Renaissance Fair so
you got like a basic bitchin yeah it'd
be like the tenth puff I gotta wear a
bowler hat yeah dude movie night stale
because that was in season 4 episode 6
of Game of Thrones
kick on father.star it does indeed
flower starts dead yeah he does indeed
encounter the bowler hat army
the Polar's yeah Ramsey bow Ramsey
bowler here all right the flayed man so
I have a follow-up wanted that didn't
work well he didn't necessarily want to
[ __ ] maybe you just wanted to get her
nowhere I hope you guys better luck at
the next Renee's Renaissance Fair yeah
that one's Black Plague theme so Matt if
you're out there good luck with your
Renaissance [ __ ] if you were wearing
uh lights on it he didn't even say what
where is San Francisco
how's Mary is that the map shows I
believe Alameda
yeah that's Hermosa Renaissance action
goes down now it's on an island yeah all
right Zach you're up okay hit me
first of all now I want to present one
without comment I just here's one that
we don't necessarily need to get into
because I feel like it's oh you broke
this right broke the rules very here's
here's this one the headline is just
Jumanji
and the body reads we made eye contact
as you were leaving more than once
it's obvious we should make more than
eye contact they went to see the second
Jumanji film like Jumanji - yeah yeah
and that one leaving the theater they
made eye contact more than once I
guarantee you this one was definitely
thinking about the rock yeah right and
what was happened to be there yeah
unless he was in the way around did you
say it was a man it's a man for 100 guys
you know m4w in Vancouver Washington
yeah as we record the first episode in
Portland my searches are coming from
Washington which makes it's fine my
second search my second miss connection
a very weird one okay so let me let me
set the scene the headline here all caps
Gary - where are you no question mark so
now the question is what is a statement
that's Gary - where are you where is
Gary all right and then this person goes
on - right mm-hmm
in 1980 you were in Arcadia California
working as a Mason area on the newly
constructed LDS Church near Santa I need
a raise
tract you're the only there temporarily
seems that you live there and work there
in either Portland Oregon or in Idaho
Falls where your daughter lived she was
seven at the time so she would be 43 or
44 years old
okay you left California in late October
in late October or early November of
1980 didn't know where you went I would
like to know I would like very much to
locate you I know it's been 36 years but
it's really important to me please
respond
okay oh my golly okay
did they have a relationship I don't
know it just seems like he was like hey
you were kind of doing construction on a
church for a bit Gary Gary where are you
yeah okay so you helped build this
church okay wait there's will they
friends okay you can't tell I can't tell
are we in Portland are you looking at
this in Portland I am and this is this
isn't Arcadia post so like the the map
shows a split on the on the five
interstate as like the central location
here which means that like this is a
post in Arcadia hmm but about Santa and
what she says I assume she yes says
seems that you lived and worked in
either Portland Oregon or Idaho Falls
where your daughter lived so I assume
that they're posting for I assume that
they're posting from Arcadia California
but posting in the Craigslist Portland
yeah because they're trying to track
somebody down okay I'm so confused so
they know that this person worked in
construction and that they had a kid
were they friends is this a stalker why
do they need to find each other again
several questions so here's here's the
thing it ends with the lines I know it's
been over 36 years but it's really
important to me please respond so the
fact that it's like a specific like 36
years yeah maybe there's like an
illegitimate child involved that's what
I'm thinking yeah that's like I don't
know why but that's what I just you
scary Gary and the poster made love
without a condom and then 36 years ago a
human was born
most ever thought it calms Jerry Gary
and a chamber of raw doggin yeah so
scary Gary and this woman made a child
who's older than any of us yeah yes and
now at this point this child was like
hey mom whose dad and she's like his
name's Gary Gary the only way I had to
contact him is through this message
board that probably well is there
anything that rules out the idea that
the person posting could be like a kid I
mean it just seems to me like this was
could be like information he's gotten
and then taken yeah that could be it to
1980 you were in Arcadia working as a
masonry you're only there temporarily it
seems that you lived and worked in
either Portland Oregon or Idaho Falls
where your daughter lived she would be
about 43 you left California in early
October or November of 1980
no I initiated the dota could be like oh
this is my half-sister or something like
that
I mean we're driving to a lot of
conclusions yeah like I think that it's
I think that it's really interesting
that after all this time like the crux
of this post is like it's been over 36
years and the only way that you can
contact somebody is by like Marty said
like just posting this race if she
doesn't know that last name or whatever
ethos so it's like yeah I'm trying to
look at my home Facebook you but wow man
can you imagine there how hard that
would be there are over 40 Gary's in the
world so there are at least 42 yeah yeah
salsa's can't confirm or deny that
that's true yeah there's nothing about
this that is I've been thinking about
you every day and I want you in my life
because it's a romantic we immediately
jump to conclusions that this is a hey
you scared Gary made the love and we've
created the life but maybe this is
something like oh you left like a
haunted icon in my home and this has
been haunting my family ever since and I
knew right that is more I need to give
you the haunted icon I didn't say it's
more likely I just said that there we
don't take conclusions immediately
you're right I don't know I think the
curse to totem is scary Gary and the
curse totem sounded way more likely a
very haunted well I like that one then
Jerry stereo Gary in the gym
rogon yeah is the chamber the church
nice chamber is the vagina also nice
we're a bad because you know yes we
don't we as we all have children so what
do you think so he thinks more likely to
to find their significant oh the blue
hat why don't we play that game at the
end of each episode be like who's the
most likely to actually succeed here
yeah yeah - what if we just thought Gary
was scary
ok I think very Terry Terry Terry that
sounds like there's a pretty more
anything scary Terry no no anything to
hurt you and scary Brandon I see scary
Gary doesn't actually run in my accent
so it's a scary Gary
what if she's what if you pronounce it
in US in her Australian accent she was
just like scary all right mine is one
that you actually started reading
because we were doing these at the same
time but decided was creepy so I told
you stop reading this is like yeah I'm
gonna break it up into this so the title
is and this was also on Poland Oregon
I gave you an uber slash lift ride last
night and it starts with okay so this is
the creepiest thing I've done in a long
time all the sweetest thing and I'm not
100% sure which is which I gave you a
ride in the Portland area in the early
hours of Saturday morning I thought you
were just about the coolest it's just a
bunch of stuff about how he likes uh and
this is also like a really good
meet-cute start yeah except again like
the a pedestrian I'm liking you are
crossing the line of customer in custody
I agree I'm lying back my initial
criticisms of this guy cuz I I do think
it's also he's like a big sick thing oh
well he does say some stuff about how
he's worried about that being like
professional unprofessional
I wonder if that's in like you clearly
none of us have ever driven
Uber's for a living or lifts or anything
but I wonder if that's in like the terms
of services like hey just don't [ __ ]
creep on your customers yeah and he
again he references that and like he's
trying to say a lot of things at all
like hey I don't know what specific zip
code you're in so I hope you don't find
this creepy but I really wanted to
mention this one and then I think this
is like a good way to do
he is super thoughtful about it there's
a pot which this is my favorite pot
where he's being like self-referential
he says hey jackass why are you being a
huge vague scaredy-cat listen first of
all I don't care for the name-calling
which is like him referencing himself
which i think is super cute second of
all this is completely unprofessional
and I don't want to freak anyone out all
out if I misread out potential
connection nor do I want to lose my job
and have some weird mark on my record
that says friggin idiot hit on client
and she thought he was away that he had
a stupid her stupid face in his mind so
the whole thing makes the guy unhireable
and also got a big idiot and a
small-time crook with the jerk brain
which I just think is really cute
yeah like the way he approaches this is
he's obviously uncomfortable with it and
has toyed with it for a while but was
like hey I had a sweet conversation with
this human so the question I want to
pose is if you meet someone who is your
oppa driver and you're super into them
what do you do like if there's someone
that you're like this person is so
interesting to me but professionally can
I ever talk to them again like what's
the solution there
I had an uber driver wait for as an if
you are the customer like can you
approach your driver or yeah like how do
you do with that situation I've had
booba drivers before try to get my
number and it's like very uncomfortable
like I would way prefer to come across
something like this on Craigslist and to
have them ask you because when you're in
the car you punked it out so like I
would think that you know there's a
power dynamic there right and you're in
someone else's calling you don't know
whether you're going like and sometimes
like it would drivers will ask questions
it's like oh so is this why you live I'm
like hey what if you didn't know that
you just didn't we didn't have that line
of conversation there was one guy who
one time tried to convince me to marry
him for a green card I was like I'm good
but thank you yeah so my thing with that
is that why do you need a green card no
give me one obviously I think that would
be illegal anyway be illegal you just
don't have the power to I don't think I
can get married in this country like ya
know it's illegal for a woman to get
married well I mean can to foreign
people get married in the US I don't
think we've ever had to foreign people
here once probably like a girl
that I know is there are 42 galleries in
the world and two farm people so my
thing with that is I think the way that
you could like get around that is they
get out of your car and then you're like
hey yep I mean we really destination
yeah even then though cuz it's like
whatever yeah your house yeah and then
maybe wait I know you live this is a
slick move not necessarily because like
maybe that's not your house you know I
mean like sure like I feel like this
kind of slick move though like girl gets
out of your car and then you roll down
the window like hey before you go are
you really cute like I'd like to hang
out with you sometime if it's not too
weird can I get your number
like is that a weird thing that's what
she's saying like at that point like the
transaction has ended that being said
like I would do it know that I'm going
to walk but you could be like oh [ __ ]
this dude knows where I live now well I
guess so so we don't know yeah it's
tough but uh yeah he also ultimately
ends up just saying all of that said if
you think this is for you and went into
a random rideshare driver and he was as
as he was into you there's some like
very weird grammatical stuff you please
contact me this is not a weird scam or
anything it's just like it's it's very
sweet he ends it saying I'm just a guy
who is trying I'm just a girl in the
world and they also don't let this be an
all-time low
good god what have I done thanks a lot
of a drunk like pretty self deprecating
yeah in a way that's like I'm aware this
is weird
hey though I can see this being like a
Jay Baruchel movie yeah yeah okay yeah I
could take that hmm yeah that being said
look I don't like I made the joke or a
customer custody I think as as the
custody I don't go stat line
professionally because they made t-shirt
the no the the person who serves the
customer yeah we didn't so as a
librarian I never tried to have sex with
the people who were getting the books as
some I had a new spin on you I find that
hard to believe I was 16 oh I was 16 and
Shelby and sex was scary huge and then I
worked at a newspaper and I was sleeping
with a girl I worked with some time so
that's fine okay you go you're on the
custody level okay no I worked at a
coffee shop and I was sleeping with a
girl
worked upon custody level and then I was
at IGN I was I was just still sleeping
with someone at the coffee shop and then
I'm al coholic can I sleep apart tender
so that's fine yeah okay that's the
things like I don't really manage to
work in your sexual history into the
first and those are all five women that
Marley's but no what I'm saying is that
no point I feel like the power dynamics
press I feel like a power dynamic of
like it's a a like if my job is to serve
you
mm-hmm you know whether it is in the
service industry or something like over
or even just like working at an
establishment like no one like just
leave people alone
well I am inclined to agree but like
what if it's the moment way or like this
is the most amazing like they could have
had a 45-minute uber ride and it's like
this is the best conversation I've had
with a person I would tractor to any
years let it go I don't know I also find
that really weakness when I get new
burrs the last thing I want to do is
talk to anyone we should really have a
silent but that's all there should be
all you have to do is when you go all
the carts I don't want to talk the worst
why is that the worst because that's
such a shitty thing to do to another
human being I'd be like excuse me you're
just here to nowhere I mean not a
settlement but have it I also just press
a fake button on my phone have a penguin
have it be very saying what I call a car
just be like hey I don't need I've been
in I've been in cars before I was in a
car with you after III latin this year
where we got in the car and the guy
started talking to us and I was like hey
man we just work a 15 hour a day like if
we could just go to the destination
that's gonna sit here and he was like
totally cool I get it but I feel like in
the same way that there's a power
situation in trying to get somebody's
number before a transaction is complete
there's a power situation in getting
into someone else's vehicle already
dismissing them and already being like I
don't want to talk to you like I don't
know like yeah it's obviously not a
one-to-one analogy there but there are
certain people I know who just want to
talk to the people and yeah like I've
I've had some really great conversations
with your dress nun [ __ ] me I don't
think ultimately somewhere along the
lines of the one hundred thousand
overrides that are given on a day to day
basis like somewhere in there is that me
meet-cute story that might right
happy I think he did this the right way
like I get thinking that that
relationship is creepy I think this dude
like pursuing it way after and not
trying super hard and who suspicious of
what he's doing is like a good way to do
that there's also that you just brought
up an interesting point like who's to
say like we don't know the timeline you
know she might have gotten out of his
car and closed the door and he's like
urea started typing out also what does
it say what
what does how long is the ride maybe he
was like this is an amazing ride it was
her five minute ride to work sure like I
was running late yeah a little thing to
be like I went to the airport that's
like a significant we were in a traffic
jam and yeah it says I gave you a ride
in the Portland area any early hours of
Saturday morning January 20th and it was
posted on January 20th so you're right
he could have done well if he gave her a
ride in the early morning hours an
airport it means it's laid up yeah he
could have gone home and had a whole day
and then type that out yeah it'd still
be also to sort of define a thing that
I'm sure a bunch of us are gonna talk
about meet cutes or in the romantic
comedies when when you know the the
star-crossed lovers that the two
characters actually have their their
first interaction together that's sort
of sweet serendipitous moment also when
you say that it's also think of Mead
cute meat cubes that's exactly what I
think of every single times Biebz of
meat yeah which is great yeah you know
what horny Tony you tell me you wouldn't
[ __ ] with the shish kebab come on yeah
horny Tony if this doesn't work out said
that cube me true also honey Tony just I
appreciate that you you thought about
what you're doing and went just like I
did we had amazing contact let me show
you my dick he's like very you know I
don't know self-aware and considerate
and kind of embarrassed about it and I
hope it works out for horny Tony yeah
well actually hasn't given any
indication that he's Tony but the three
of our choices yes fat Matt not the Hat
horny tony is gary gary who do we think
is the most look ranked the most likely
to get together starting with a loss
silence
wait who's most likely to get together
with Elana between a half now that's
scary Gary and horny Joe uh well I had
Matt yeah that guy was balla hats and
walks at a renascent yeah he'd be my to
get with me I I I'm voting for forty
Tony Tony Tony horny Henry is really
good Henry's a pretty good Tony okay
honey Tony I think he's the one that
based on what he is written is most
likely to but if she again like if she's
going to the airport early hours of
Saturday morning then maybe she lives in
a different city so troops but I would
say he's number one
I think Matt the Hat is probably number
two because that one's really specific
and then scary Gary that one seems
almost impossible yeah like how is that
going
that's exactly how I would rank them as
well yeah the only one I care about is
scary Gary because I want to figure out
what's going on those beguile I want to
know what's about that haunted totem and
the second one is the totem yes this is
like a trilogy how's it what's the oh
man I don't know
Dora's meeting Gary Gary and the [ __ ] I
should have used that cop scary Gary did
the plan be the totem get worked into
the storyline but worth the time the
totem was a condom what if it's a totem
is a condom that when you put it on it
is one of those things where it like
exists outside of time ins time its face
like dr. Manhattan and so by wearing a
condom at one point your life you have
worn a condom throughout all of you what
is happening dr. Madden was one of the
main character with dr. Manhattan not
sure what's happening so he puts on the
the beguil'd condom the totem right and
it sort of exists if it like doesn't it
transcends time its face and so I did
one moment you know
just wait one moment dr. Manhattan was
on Mars at one moment he was you know at
his birth at one moment he was making
love it was why if it wasn't he's at the
end of the world and so this condom sort
of has that thing where it doesn't need
to to abide by our human and silly
definitions of time and space so I feel
like that's I appreciate your creativity
Thanks yep all right did you have a
different ranking I was no I was Gary
Gary I wanted scary Gary number one well
that's what you want one know what's
most likely I agree I want scary Gary
most likely is the the [ __ ] new bird
because he might get her again sure I
don't know how many people are in
Portland like I've had the same uber
driver a couple times have you really
yeah you know I really solve this
conundrum I feel like we saw pretty much
nothing but um the best of luck to
everyone if anyone has any submissions
for this yeah I'm pretty sure you can
tweet at us with the hashtag I'll walk I
didn't check if anything else is for
that but wouldn't it be cool if it's
like if it's like some kind of like
recreational group for something and
then we just like every now and then
what if whatever those is yeah I think I
think it's a legal obligation at the end
of every podcast that you're supposed to
provide self promote yeah you could find
me on Twitter at scared Gary I promise
I'm currently so no I I'm at Twitter on
Twitter at McVitie MCB IgG I TTY and I
do a bunch of shows with these fools as
well yeah Sam you can find me on IG n
and on the NBC podcast and I'm at
zacharias t that's as EA CH a are I us D
and I'm a LAN piece you can find me at
Charlotte zone which is just my name in
the middle of Charizard thank you all
for listening you can check out bonus
content over on patreon.com slash our
Alana zone where every episode is also
available early and the support is over
there are really the only reason we were
able to put this whole thing together
if not you can contribute to the podcast
by sharing a screenshot of a miss
connection you've found with us on
Twitter at
see podcast all by using the hashtag loc
we'll see you in a couple of weeks a
next episode is February 28th